the elements under snicker represent the
life and legacy of Malcolm X though red
blue and white represents the American
flag using an online tool from the
virtual course maker yellow-brick for
our colors stitching students at Meyer
Levin's School for the Performing Arts
are adding a sense of style and science
to sneaker culture where does the
passion for shoes come from for you guys
oh I mean it's a shoe first off you know
add character to your look and second I
mean who doesn't like to follow a little
template this program is new for younger
students it was originally designed for
grown-ups like Detroit Pistons point
guard Langston Galloway this is a one of
my basic shoes right here a collector of
more than 1,500 sneakers he wanted to
learn about the business as he was
launching his sportswear line LG Kicks
we met up off court after a game at
Madison Square Garden before the NBA
suspended its season and where he was
already talking about life after
basketball me and my wife we just had to
figure out ways that we come
you know be a part of entrepreneur side
when I was a kid just like yourself I
couldn't really afford sneakers during a
FaceTime chat a few days later Galloway
joined the middle schoolers from my
eleven to learn about their designs they
really get to dig deep into where their
talents lie George Patterson is the
principal at Meyer Levin the first
school to partner with yellow brick in a
pilot program which combines their
online coursework with what they've
learned in the classroom we used it
because it was engaging but we also used
it before there was a way for us to like
teach business to the kids so instead of
always being just a consumer how do we
get to that other side how do we learn
how to market how do we learn how to
design this shoe represents history
lessons from history also influenced
their designs as shoes all about Harriet
Tubman shot go back everyday I'm just
one or two people and that's meaningful
to you yeah why because people think
that because I'm small I can't do
anything but they're wrong about that
yeah the kids are able to engage create
the art create the work and then self
assess because a big cage made they want
to do well they want a design they want
to learn imagine that I'm thinking about
architectural design each of the
students we met saw different careers
and none in the sneaker industry medical
doctor but each credits the course for
expanding on the fundamentals we need to
know math of course because if you're
gonna design a sneaker you need to know
like the ratios and stuff oh that's some
science in science
yeah I was a science teacher weave
realizes that there's a huge opportunity
to make this available to more schools
Rob King ins is the founder and CEO of
yellow brick the company is now offering
schools nationwide free access to the
program tested and approved right here
in Brooklyn
in fact like right now with the
coronavirus you know going on there's a
lot of schools are being forced to go
online and one of the biggest challenges
was going online is well how do you keep
students engaged after the school is
closed due to the Corona
iris seventh-grader marvin leon shared
images of sneakers he designed from home
each a reflection of the times when the
pandemic retreats and the NBA returns
Langston Galloway plans to wear one of
the designs from the students at Meyer
Levin Moe language CBS News New York